attention vous entrez dans un monde sans
mensonge
[Musique]
alors ce que ces messieurs ont choisi un
oui moi je veux pas vous prendre
d'entrée
moi je vous prends une tomate mozza si
et c'est moi qui habite en ce milieu à
merci voici du coup je vous prends une
entrée je vous reprends du saumon fumé
alors si je peux me permettre je vous
déconseille le saumon fumé 1 déjà parce
que c'est la truite et puis surtout on
l'achète en barquette au supermarché à
côté c'est burrito j'aime
ah ouais bah vous nous conseillez quoi
rien sans les connaître
15 bal pourpre à bouche et non prenez du
pain c'est qu'à mieux et en plat moi je
vous prends le tartare de boeuf si de la
viande crue dans un restaurant monsieur
l aventure avec parce qu'on a le frigo
qui a planté hier heureusement que
l'hygiène est pas passé parce que s'ils
ont fermé bouclard n'en portait sur le
burger ils sont bien là c'est pareil
c'est l'avion dash l élu mérite
ouais et on va vous prendre du vin aussi
s'il vous plaît monsieur away alors là
tu m'étonnes avec les deux têtes de
piccolo vous avez tous les deux surtout
le gros alors on part sur quoi sont dues
boisé de charpentes et on va savoir quoi
en fait c'est pas tu trouves moi je
récite s'automatise chaud et vous les
conseillez quoi non mais moi j'y connais
rien hein alors en général je conseille
jamais premier trop cher donc ses
cahiers on part directement sur le
deuxième et l'envoi de pas mal surtout
pour vous car on est pas mal et voilà mr
à l'école au lycée pas de pourboire non
on se dit vous aviez déjà un salaire
donc tu ce beau faire des blagues sur
google bradley
c'est qu'il [ __ ] qui a pissé par terre
c'est moi d'habitude je nettoie mais
quand je suis pas chez moi j'en ai rien
à [ __ ]
[Musique]